the goal of the expedition was to
explore the byock biotic diversity as
much of the Philippines as we couldn't
it as many different environments and
but we didn't restrict it to lose to
Islands Luzon in the north and Mindoro
just south there I was one of the
Academy scientists that was fortunate
enough to go to the Philippines in do
research in ternary or very little
research has been done one of the things
that we've been trying to do is document
how much biodiversity is there and how
much of it is unknown no one has been
into the area that we studied and it was
evidenced by all the discoveries that we
made we continue to find new species
every time we go there and that curve of
species accumulation hasn't leveled off
in 20 years
you know one of the things that we
thought about this expedition that we
would find new things but we had no idea
what the magnitude of that would be we
found basically at least 300 new species
of plants and animals on this expedition
in in the course of a month I think
indeed most unexpected things we found
where came from the deep water component
and because you don't know what you're
going to get when you put a trawl net
down a thousand meters or whatever to
the bottom of the sea and you bring it
up you have no idea what you're going to
find so we found things like deep sea
sea pens and corals that I had never
encountered before from extreme depth I
guess that my favorite discovery was
that new shark I wasn't expecting it I
certainly didn't imagine that I get a
new shark species in the very first trap
that we set here it came so I guess that
was my favorite but those eels are
pretty exciting too my favorite find was
a little sea slug that I had found it's
in a group that I've been studying
extensively it's probably about an half
an inch in length and it was a brand-new
species but what was really cool about
it is that it had this elongate tail
coming out behind in of its body that
looks sort of like a Labrador Retriever
or something so I called it the puppy
dog slug and since we've been back been
able to sequence its DNA put it into the
context of the other things that we know
and we've been able to verify it yeah
it's a completely new thing another goal
of the expedition had to do with
conservation and protecting areas and we
worked with lots of conservation
agencies in the Philippines the
Fisheries Department particularly in
Manila the department interior they want
to know what's there and any information
they can get from outside scientists is
a is what they are want that's where we
come in just giving him an idea of
what's there basically a lot of what we
didn't expect at all was almost in every
trawl we found a large quantity of
plastics
plastic garbage that has sunk to the
bottom of the sea every time we went
into the water there you saw plastics
and particularly if the wind was blowing
a particular direction you would see you
know almost a raft of plastic bags
floating by and then these things
eventually fall down to the bottom when
you're diving on coral reefs
you know disposable diapers are draped
over coral heads it's it's really quite
disturbing to see that kind of stuff
we pull the Nets and when the Nets would
come up 50% of the net bag the
collection bag was full of plastic full
of cans full old clothes a trash among
the plastic you found your specimens but
you had to dig through the plastic to
find the organisms in some cases and
that's not a good sign and we don't know
if that's just in this one area or it's
worldwide it doesn't mean that people in
the Philippines are are more careless
they're not a wealthy nation like we are
here in the US and the challenges are
greater but certainly the will to
effectively create a better environment
is there and is in the hearts and the
minds of the Filipino people and I'm
confident that they're going to come up
with solutions
you